You spending the summer with your Auntie Barb, sending me away for the summer what a cliche
So you're from here? Yeah wait no, okay, okay. Eww
Hide this
You get high?
Can you take me home
This look she gave me man. Hey. Hey yourself, I was hoping you'd show up. Guess who got lucky? I can't get her out of my mind.
Would you say if I told you I wanted to start something weed.
What's this one? That's a zip. If more people bought these, my life will be a lot easier
We should sell more of those
The problem is we're dealing dime bags
to teenagers. We need customers who buy in bulk. You didn't know how to use a bong and now you're trying to tell me how to
flip weed
I have something you've been looking for. How do we know you're not cops? That's a good question.
Cops can't do that sit down
This is gonna be more money then either of us have ever seen.
You're not caught up in anything shady, right
Lazy sweetheart play something celebratory
Happens every summer
Money here is so heavy you can't breathe.
nights turn long and sleepless
When you long for cooler times
You know what it is. It's gonna tear you apart
Can't hold on to everything. I think some things you can, and I hope you're good at being hurt
You